this is the ramsay show
[Applause]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsey show where
debt is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw as the status symbol of choice
i'm dave ramsey your host number one
best-selling author
of the book own your past change your
future dr john deloney ramsey
personality is my co-host today as we
talk to you and help you with building
wealth doing work that you love and
creating actual
amazing relationships the phones are
open the phone number is triple eight
eight two five 825-5225
christian starts off this hour in new
jersey hi christian welcome to the
ramsey show
hi mr ramsey mr deloney how are you guys
today better than we deserve what's
up um
i'm happy to hear i've been a listener
to the ramsey show since i was in my
early 20s and i appreciate your advice
so i'm calling because i recently got my
master's degree and i'm going to be
starting a new job for the first time
ever i'm going to have extra money at
the end of the month once my bills and
savings are taken care of good for you
put your master's in
thank you it's in biology with a
concentration in ecology and evolution
wonderful what are you going to be doing
i'm going to be an environmental
scientist oh ding ding what's your
income going to be
55k all right good for you way to go i
love it
so and so you have this trouble now you
just got too much money
well i have more i'm going to have more
money once i start my job than i've ever
had before
and i was wondering how i can best
utilize this money to financially secure
my future
it's my understanding that i'm supposed
to put 15 of my pain to retirement
savings i'm unsure if that is before and
after
taxes and also i'm an avid favor
um however i feel as though i'm just
saving to watch my bank account grow
right and i wanted to ask how can i
intentionally take action to ensure that
i'm financially prepared for my future
you you are truly a scientist incredible
i love it i love it very process driven
you're going to be so wealthy oh good
for you all right so you have no debt i
take it
technically no well what's technically
me
well sir um my parents were very very
kind they bought a car for me when i was
in grad school the loan is under my name
but they're taking care of the payments
nope
nope if it's your car and you're
responsible for the debt you have debt
we need to clear that up
okay mom and dad being in debt on your
behalf is not cool
so how much do you owe on your car
it's approximately 7 000. good deal well
you're going to knock that out first
then you're going to build an emergency
fund of three to six months of expenses
then you're going to save 15 of your
income and if you want to save beyond
that i would say you're probably saving
for your first house would you would you
agree with that
okay
would you agree with that
um sure i never thought that i could be
able to afford a house but um that's a
good master's degree why couldn't you
get a house
christian
you're gonna be able to get a house what
did your parents do for a living
uh well my father he worked for the usps
and my mother works at an adult
care center for adults with disabilities
so you have two parents who worked
really hard but they didn't make a ton
of money is that right
yes okay i come from a very similar
situation dad's a police officer mom was
staying at home it was tough and dave
has given me an incredible gift
and the gift is this idea of ratios
which is i have been so
scared of money my whole life waiting
for the next shoe to drop that i'm
somebody that like you likes to watch
the account grow just because it makes
me feel safer and it's an illusion and
so
it's this idea of what does safe feel
like and it's this ratio so you're
making more money probably both your
parents combined have made and
you're going to enjoy some of that
you're going to spend some out you're
going to save some of that and whichever
one of those categories is the one that
feels the most awkward to you then
you're going to have to be disciplined
in that category and it sounds strange
to say you're going to have to have
discipline in enjoying your life but
that's one thing that you struggle with
because you've been fighting you're
fighting or fleeing your whole life
right
yes yeah so you're here you did it and
so now what you're going to do is you're
going to say i have to go out with
friends once a month or twice a month
and i gotta spend money on something
like on a new something i'm gonna have
to build that in it's like federal law
if you score a touchdown you must do a
touchdown dance
i mean it's that if you're making some
money you have to enjoy part of it right
and enjoy giving part of right and enjoy
saving part out i took a call in my show
the other day someone said that i i
can't give how do i do that i said you
practice put it on your thing and make
yourself do it right absolutely and
watch people's body language but
whatever one of those things um some
people spend too much don't save you got
to practice it you got to make that a
discipline yeah you're not going to have
to practice savings that one's going to
come to you easy
and so on so all right james is with us
james is in phoenix hi james how are you
i'm better than i deserve dave how are
you just the same sir how can we help
awesome just had a question for you guys
i felt a little
double-minded in this financial journey
kind of like foot on the gas and then
feeling like not having enough family
time and so then
swinging to the other end of things and
um
yeah just really not wanting to
go for it in life um some of these
financial sacrifices at the sacrifice of
family and you know that emotional
connection with family so just wondering
even just practical
tips on how you can make that happen you
know here's the thing even like the top
guys
if you did the stuff if you did the
intense thing where you're sacrificing
your family for an extended period of
time you'd be sacrificing your family
when you do it for a short period of
time in a sprint called gazelle
intensity like a year or two years and
you're busting it for a short period of
time you're not sacrificing your family
you're sacrificing for your family
because your kids are going to have a
completely different life because you
got up off the freaking couch
and we're watching netflix in the name
of family time and went and did
something instead so the gazelle
intensity thing usually doesn't last 18
to 24 months because you're out of debt
how much debt have you got not counting
your house
we're almost out of debt we just have a
few grand of medical bills that are
somewhat pending um and then we build
the emergency fund so where is it that
you're
why is it you're going to be intense for
so long then
i guess i guess maybe not even the baby
steps but just uh
just the idea of building for the future
sometimes
is uh you know it's a
sacrifice yes
let me let me
family at the expense of just building a
happy future look how many hours would
you be working while you're doing this
to build the emergency fund no to do
what you're talking about
where you're losing your family i'm
confused you're working a 40-hour week
or what
yeah i think um i think my wife and i
were both quality time people so we feel
you know the stress if we hit like 50
hours a week we just are feeling it so
let me tell you this if you are with
your family and you owe a bunch of money
and you're not safe you will be in the
physical proximity of your family but
you will not be with them and your kids
will feel that tension
that frustration and they will think
it's their fault
the greatest gift you can give your kids
is to set them up on a safe foundation
and if you owe somebody money you're not
safe i i would set your life up where it
runs perfectly after baby step 3 on 40
or 50 hours a week yeah and if you're
doing that you should be that's the way
we teach that's moving from intensity to
intentionality and you're gonna be just
fine if you max out at 50 a week that's
fine no problem
nobody around here is telling you to
work 80 a week after you hit baby step
3.
[Music]
look i love real estate and i want you
to have a house but i don't want a house
to have
you
that's why you need to get in touch with
churchill mortgage to make sure you do
this right these guys are awesome
they'll help you get on a smarter
mortgage plan because they're committed
to doing what's right for
you
that means they check in every year with
free consultations to help you stay on
the right plan they show you how to save
money and interest so you can build
wealth faster they walk you through the
total cost of your loan so you can make
the best choice
basically they care that's why we call
them ramsey trusted you can achieve
debt-free home ownership and churchill
is here to help go to their site
churchillmortgage.com
ramsey to start your approval or get
more information
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
the building wealth live
tour is in full swing we were in las
vegas last week with almost 3 000 folks
we are going to be next thursday one
week from today
in orlando may 19th and we've got over 3
000 there that event is within 100
tickets of selling out if you want to
come i would suggest you get on the
website orlando today
go to ramsey ramseysolutions.com
events and you can get a four pack for
60
or single tickets at 25
that's a way you and some friends can
take some friends all of our events have
the 25 or four pack uh starting at sixty
dollars orlando is sixty dollars phoenix
arizona will be there september the 13th
sacramento uh november the first
minneapolis november 10th san antonio
november the 15th it's rachel cruz
george camel
uh me dr john deloney and of course ken
coleman and we'll be there talking about
how to build real wealth in a world
that's lost its ever loving
on things going on out there so it's
going to be a lot of fun it's an evening
event we would love to have you all of
these are i think thursday maybe maybe
that 13th of the september might be a
tuesday but they're all like that kind
of a night out for you your spouse your
friends or your whatever you want to do
again a four packs beginning at 60
check it all out at ramseysolutions.com
events our question of the day comes
from
blinds.com find out for yourself why
blinds.com is the number one online
retailer of custom window coverings free
samples free shipping and with the new
promos they run every month you'll save
even more use the promo code ramsey and
you can get the best deal
today's question comes from nathan in
mississippi nathan writes how can i stop
worshiping money i'm currently on baby
step 3b and throughout these years of
grinding away to build my savings i
found myself so focused on the goal that
it's becoming all consuming i work as a
truck driver and i work anywhere from 13
to 15 hours a night i'm tired and i'm
burnt out recently i feel god is telling
me to slow down and go at his pace
how can i still attack this thing
without feeling like i'm putting the
money before everything else
whenever i think of the word worship
dave um
i think of fear
think of
in awe of
and
like we just talked with the last caller
here i i spent years worshiping money
because it was something i was scared of
whether it was the scarcity i didn't
know how it worked i didn't know how
these stock markets were going up and
down and my neighbor's houses were worth
whatever and so it took over and when i
got some insight about it and some
knowledge about it so people around me
that could coach me through it it lost
its power because i got some i had a
relationship uh i learned more about it
i wasn't scared of it anymore um and i
think about worshiping god and i think
there's an awe and a reverence and a
uh
i would say like a destructive fear but
a healthy
relational fear there um what do you
think about that i think that's accurate
um the
the the thing is
um
you step to the side of any item that
becomes an idol
and you set it in its proper place in
your
mind and in your spiritual walk in your
life
and you say okay this is an item
it is a tool
money is really of no value except for
what it can do
it it makes a lousy god
it makes a lousy master yep um and also
um makes a a a lousy slave even so uh
you know you you want to control the
money not it control you
and there's a difference that you know
the only larry burkett used to say the
only difference in saving and hoarding
is your attitude
it's not an amount
it's not a process it's not a level of
intentionality it's not a level of
diligence both are very diligent savers
investors and hoarders
they're very it's just your attitude
about it it's what are you trying to get
from it
not what are you doing right and not the
amount and not how many years you've
been doing or something like that so i'm
very intentional with money i actually
always have been even before i went
broke i've always been intentional
uh but but i i am a manager of it
since i went broke before that i was
more of a worshiper of it i thought it
was going to bring me happiness
if you think it's going to be your
provider yes then you've got it you've
given it too much power
and then you can set to the side but you
know the fact that you've been working
hard and hitting some goals and you want
to slow down
that's not a worshiping issue that's
just a realization that i'm at baby step
3b which is where we tell people to move
from intensity to intentionality like
the last caller yeah and you have to do
that you have to change your identity
right your identity was one of running
and crushing and getting this thing done
and now you're moving to one of
intentionality right place right time
now what are we going to do moving
forward right now i'm not going for a
live stream i'm not a sprinter i'm a
marathoner there you go i changed my
name yeah and uh i used to be a sprinter
because i had to do that i had to run
the cheetah was chasing me so i had to
run and and now i can just calm down and
and i don't have to work seven days a
week 15 hours a night you know and uh
god is telling you slow down
i think that probably was god
and uh but it's it but worshiping money
you can do when you don't have any when
you have a lot when you're in the middle
of it uh when you've got the other side
of it you can worship at any time that's
a position of the heart it's not a
position of the money
or a baby step or anything like that um
and you know that does say
so here's the thing again i think it's a
good both of these are questions are
somewhat
parallel uh and so
it's really important for you folks out
there to hear
i am all about we at ramsey are all
about
you going absolutely crazy and i don't
care how hard you work i don't care if
you're working 40 hours a day
for a short period of time to get your
freaking mess cleaned up you spent four
years five years nine years making a
mess you are not gonna clean that up in
nine days
you are gonna have to roll up your
sleeves and sacrifice and hurt
there's gonna be pain involved
discomfort
inconvenience i'm not going to see my
baby your baby's asleep while you're
working you need to get your butt in
gear and clean up your mess for the sake
of your family that type of stuff is
gazelle intensity we call it is for baby
steps one through three and is generally
somewhere in the 18 to 24 month range i
don't i don't ask people to do that for
five years it's very unusual sometimes
you have to but it's very unusual most
of the time it's one month to 24 months
and you are done
once you get out of debt everything but
your house and you have your emergency
fund in place we suggest
at ramsey that you take your foot off
the gas back it off a little bit
go into marathon mode
and now you've got a more balanced
schedule you drop some of those side
hustles and now you're going to spend
more time with your family which by the
way is going to be a better quality of
time because you don't have this debt
hanging over you and you're not
preoccupied with mastercard calling your
phone while you're trying to play with
your kids
and i also think it's important that for
the last caller too
there are seasons of every single job
when these are 60 or 70 hour a week
months right and that's just part of
life and i think the challenge that most
have is they don't know how to have that
conversation at home with their spouse
with their kids
um and i'm thinking back to before the
before we went through this book season
like sheila and i sat down with the
calendar and said here's what this is
going to look like now yeah and she's
all in got it and then here's what it's
going to look like when my foot comes
off the gas right and we can reconnect
and then this so i think it's about
being intentional about it like you
mentioned it it's about being
intentional but you can't be scared of
hard work man in the name of
if i miss this in the name of nurture if
i miss this one game then i'm the
terrible dad and yeah the worst and all
that kind of stuff it's not but don't
set your life up where you miss them all
right for the restaurant absolutely yes
because you're so freaking broke you
can't breathe that's right you know so
get the mess straightened up and and
sometimes it's just to hit a goal yeah
sometimes it's just to do some stuff
like uh tomorrow
uh
i for the next three days sharon and i
have rachel's kids
and we won't be doing anything
except rachel's kids for three days
uh
the next thursday
i will leave here early in the morning
and end up in orlando and i will have
lunches and dinners and events and
building wealth and then we have entree
leadership summit that begins on sunday
i'm speaking at a church on sunday
morning and uh for the next seven days
after that i'm probably going to do
80 hours
and i don't even have to work right but
i'm doing that to hit some goals but
there's a ebb and flow to this
that you know and that's scheduled i'm
emotionally prepared and it's not
forever it's for seven whole days he's
not gonna kill old dave you know he's
not gonna whine about it you know but
i'm gonna hit some serious goals during
that time and our team is gonna hit some
serious goals during that time and i'm
leading the charge
the front of the horse with the sword
pointed forward you know
and uh hey game on but i'm not doing
that 80 hours a week anymore
seven days a week for
you know months on end and you did it
for a season a week for this right i did
a long time ago for this right and my
kids all survived it barely
this is the ramsey chef
[Music]
uh
[Music]
still on baby step number one huh
how'd you guess
with health care costs rising learn how
christian healthcare ministries can help
you make the most out of your budget
visit chministries.org
budget don't worry it's worth it
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
dr john dolone ramsey personality is my
co-host today this is the ramsey show in
the lobby of ramsey solutions on the
debt-free stage donny and lauren are
with us welcome guys thank you for
having us so good to have you where do
you live bakersfield california ah
welcome to nashville and how much debt
have you paid off a hundred and eight
thousand dollars good for you and how
long did that take 13 months all right
and your range of income during that
time during that time we were at 106 000
and we bumped it up to about 148 000
whoa nice jump
all right and what kind of debt was the
108 man we were normal people we had
credit cards we had a solar loan student
loan uh trailer loan furniture and a
furniture loan too were those people
normal people just everything yeah there
wasn't a debt you couldn't like
man yeah well zero percent come on yeah
it's free yeah
i love it okay so how long you guys been
married
going on eight years okay what what
happened 13 months ago
well you know our journey kind of went
back further than that when i decided to
take out 60 000 in student loans man i
had
no way or to figure out how we're going
to pay for this or how i was going to
pay for this and it was just a burden
that i carried 60 thousand dollars and
fast forwarded it to you know our
marriage i carried that forward in and
i was i was embarrassed by it
so
um and we also accrued additional debt
like we said you know we were living
like normal people
um but
through that time i was always just
trying to figure out how can we pay off
all this mess that i and we created
and so
i was listening to your podcast your
youtube show you know i was watching it
and listening to it on my way to work
talking about it trying to get her on
board
you know even so much that the church
that we intend we attend at on canyon
hills assembly of god in bakersfield
california they've uh they asked me to
lead a financial peace course a couple
years ago yeah so that's kind of where
our journey began yeah so when donnie
first taught financial peace in january
of 2020 right before the pandemic of
course we we were on a single income and
i wasn't able to attend every class and
in particular i missed session two which
i feel like is the one you need to hear
but uh
so when he started getting excited about
the classes he was teaching and what he
was learning i wasn't on board i felt
like
you know i'm
we're already on a tight budget we're
how can we possibly cut anything more
back i just i squashed him down and i
knew it wasn't right but
it it just didn't seem like something
feasible well fast forward to july of
2020 i picked up a part-time from home
social media content creation job and
that was our first taste of wow we've
got a little chunk of money you know
this is exciting we could save it and we
didn't really have the right mentality
yet and then five months from there i
picked up a second part-time job it was
another opportunity just the lord gave
to me
and doing hr work which was my prior
experience
so now i've replaced about two-thirds of
my income is very exciting but we were
still ish we still believed in our
costco credit card that you know earning
those points and we weren't following a
budget we were overspending so
when the pandemic started kind of get
easing up a little bit
it was time to coordinate again in
january of 2021 and so i attended and i
saw see session two of fpu and it was
everything for me it changed how i saw
debt it changed it's not something that
should be a part of you that's normal
that you know everybody has it it's
something to get mad at it's something
to realize this is taking your future
this is taking your legacy and i i was
ready to just
be all in correct so that night we went
home and had a heart-to-heart
conversation and
that night we decided
we are not going to live like normal
people anymore we are going to change
the course of our lives and our kids
lives and we
were all in we were all in and so we
dove right into it and started working
the steps yep we cut up the credit card
we set up our financial snowball
we uh we started taking out the little
ones one and it was so exciting you know
paid off the credit card paid off the
furniture paid off the trailer and we're
like feeling invincible and i'm like
what else can i do i'm gonna get a third
job let's do this yeah so i picked up a
third job yeah all while raising two
kids and you know staying home you know
full-time mom yeah hours were crazy uh
late nights early mornings it was so
worth it because the fire was there i
finally
got it and i finally realized why
one one spouse can't just do this you
have to have both on board because even
if he's teaching financial peace
university yep
yes exactly did i miss that part of the
story but you actually have to attend it
for a whole year yeah he's been teaching
it and you're standing over here with
your arms crossed going no way donny
what were you thinking you know i mean
you had to be going ah
you know i was patient you know i i made
it work i made a lot of mistakes too you
know i mean i love to spend you know and
so but uh you know she was patient the
lord we were praying and you know
the lord spoke to you yeah and so once i
finally got on board and we're taking
care of this oh it's game on now it was
everything and that was a long year for
him teaching financial peace university
meanwhile we're using the costco credit
card
that's
you know when we did the numbers we were
overspending by something like 400 a
month you know all for a 700 check at
the you know one time a year or
something crazy it was like this math
does not work it's all about the math
and you know it's hard to
it's hard to get there and you just have
to really look at yourself and realize
cool yeah yeah so when we uh when we
finally got to the student loan the car
market the used car market was pretty
good yeah and so during that time um we
we have a we had a 2016 uh toyota
4runner and we were already you know
paying off debt but then at this point
we're like what can we do to accelerate
um paying off the student loan so we
decided to sell our car
and um i took it to the dealership and
they offered us just you know a couple
thousand dollars less than i paid for
brand new and so we went down
and i put a big chunk down to the
student loan and a little bit of that
money we bought a used high mileage car
we call it my dave ramsey car
oh
yeah and so
yeah and at that point we only had 18
000 left and man we were just thinking
what else can we what else can we sell i
mean we were looking around the house
what can we do we were so close um and
then uh man uh we were looking to the
side of the house and we're like
why not the trailer so i mean even
though we just bought it we decided
eighteen thousand dollars less
left on the student loan let's just go
ahead and sell it so do you wish you
still had the trailer
no we uh would i wish yeah no i mean
feels i mean is that a good trade you
made yes
it was 100 worth it correct and you know
even just the trade of knowing if we
really want another one which we do
we're going to save cash for it down the
road and it's going to be okay correct
and so you know
what
once we decided to sell the trailer you
know um
we
that net that monday we went down and
paid off um my student our student loan
and we became debt free in february of
2022.
it was awesome that's amazing well done
you guys it's a great journey and
another big motivator was you know his
company is being sold and so
we really looked at each other and we
thought we have to get an emergency
going we don't know what our future is
going to be
what are we willing to do and we were
willing to do anything yeah and because
of your guys's teachings you know um
i'm not stressed and worried about it
you know what's in god's hands our we're
okay our kids are okay we're doing fine
you know so that's so cool good for you
guys gosh it's awesome so proud of y'all
welcome
thank you very well done we got a copy
of baby steps millionaires for you
that's the next chapter in your story
for sure and uh we're also going to give
you a gift card for financial peace in
every dollar the ramsey plus
subscription for a year that'll be since
you're a coordinator you'll be able to
give that away i'm sure to find somebody
that needs that help and uh same thing
with a total money makeover book you'll
have an extra one of those as well to
give away and pay it forward so we'll
step into your generosity step here
thank you so good stop good stuff you
guys well done
all right it's donnie and lauren from
bakersfield california 108 000 paid off
in 13 months making 106 to 148 count it
down let's hear a debt-free scream yep
three two one
whatever it takes
love it bust it whatever it takes sell
it sell it
this is the ramsay show
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
dr john dolone ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
jane's in phoenix hi jane welcome to the
ramsay show
hey dave hey what's up
awesome longtime listener first time
caller
yes so anyway my my question is um i'm
36 years old um i'm getting
unengaged you
it took us a long time to find each
other um anyway i uh
i have always since i was a little kid
like
money equals security for me
and i've actually completed all of those
baby steps before i even knew who dave
ramsey was
and so i just want to tell you like
that's like a huge part of
you know what kind of makes me whole as
bad as that nice might sound but the
ultimate goal is you know financial
freedom
um you know i don't
i don't make money to go buy gucci
purses and stuff like that and i'm
betting the guy that you're marrying is
not a saving tight wad like you
that is correct opposites attract i've
heard
that that is also true you know he's the
the best man that he he treats me so
well he loves me so much
it's just that we had different
upbringings when it came to finances and
so
i asked him to sign a prenup um because
i have built a little bit of a nest egg
for myself what is a little bit of a
mistake
a million dollars okay and he has
nothing
yep exactly
he's got an entire car
yeah he's got his car okay now the good
the good thing is he was in some toxic
relationships in the past
and he has um
you know become a better version of
himself and he's learned from these
toxic relationships you know trying to
impress women with
with stuff right how old is he
42. okay i've been married before
he was married in his 20s but
uh nope never married no kid all right
cool
and uh so i asked him to sign a prenup
um because you know
finances are my security and
it would be very detrimental to me if
something didn't work out
and i lost half of that
so
he has been really cool and he uh
understands that just by knowing
what's your question
the question is how do i
dave how do i deal with like
someone that is not on the same
financial
you know
level of me not level in terms of income
because he could make that in his what
he does for work he could make that up
but like
how do i
how do i control my anxiety of like
right now
i'll let john address that let me back
up about three steps and i want to i
want to hit i want to hit two things and
then i want him to step into the
relationship part of this too
um the
nut number one i do agree and i rarely
agree
but in your case the uh the difference
is so extreme and when there's an
extreme difference of a million dollars
or more
i do recommend a prenup so i do agree
with the prenup i don't agree with why
you did it
okay you did it trying to protect where
you feel like security comes from
mistake
because security doesn't come from money
i mean it gives you some security it
gives you some sense of peace but you're
placing more on it than you should and
you actually said that right
right okay so i i don't want you uh
doing this to protect this
from him i just think it's general
wisdom because the differences are so
extreme and i'll even go a step further
the reason that i used to tell people
never do a prenup but the reason i
started doing where the differences are
extreme is not you and him but it's your
wacky relatives
and they go well he married a
millionaire so i'm gonna jump in here
and i got a whole agenda now and here
comes crazy eddie the cousin right and
something and you and he he's got a nice
barrier now he goes i gotta prenup i
can't help so uh you know you can kind
of reel crazy eddie out at thanksgiving
dinner and so it shuts shuts down the
weirdness around these differences but
what you're identifying that john and i
can both speak to is that you have to
get on the same page prior to marriage
about how we're going to handle money
he's never going to be as extreme as you
are and you're never going to be as
loose as he is but you've got to get
each other and you got to get closer
together than you are now because you're
going to tear each other's eyes out
otherwise
here i'm going to i'm going to be real
honest with you is that cool
yeah yeah please i feel like you have a
part of you
that you want to stay yours
and you want to build a brick wall
around it because this is mine
and then the rest of me i'm going to
marry out
you can't do that
that's not how your marriage is gonna
it's gonna end up he's not gonna ever
fully have you now i'm not saying he has
access to a million dollars in a
checking account i'll follow dave's uh
financial wisdom there what i'm saying
is you have told him
i don't find security in you i don't
find security in our marriage i don't
find security in the same theology i
find security in this bank account that
you can't touch now let's get married
and go make a life together
so it's it's a sentiment it's a moving
forward so
i wouldn't start the conversation with
him we i handle money better than you
you never have i would start the
conversation like this
we are about to sign up for forever with
each other
and i'm only doing this once
here's what i need
having us on the same page with a budget
makes me feel safe it makes me feel
heard and it makes me be able to sleep
at night and he's gonna say
having you spend some money for us to go
dancing and go laugh a little bit and go
on vacation makes me feel seen and heard
and you can go cool i'm all in and he
can go cool i'm all in and he's gonna
have to learn some new tools that he
doesn't have so you're gonna have to be
patient with him and curious and
practice and you don't know how to cut
loose and spend some money and go
dancing and he's gonna teach you how to
do that that's the beauty of this thing
moving forward if you both make it a
point to meet each other's needs the
best you can you hear what i'm saying
yeah this is a core issue
and then i guess the other kind of
question i have john and dave is like um
i've never had to support someone and
right now he just recently switched jobs
and it takes a while to kind of build up
your book of business and um right now
i'm paying rent and i'm also
giving him extra cash i have um when i
get paid
married
yeah right you don't give people cash
you're not married yeah okay he he
doesn't he is not making anything right
now and he needs to go do door dash yeah
he's gonna start mowing live
he did he did get the sign up for uber
so i don't know the process of that but
he like he can make money tonight go
door knocking you've got to he's got to
figure that out
and and
you when you get married it's y'all's
money
you're not paying his rent it's y'all's
money
yeah and one day you might lose your job
and he's working you're not you're not
supporting anyone when you're married
it's hours it's ours
right right well i am supporting him
right now
giving me anxiety yeah that should give
you anxiety
and if this is if he's if he's giving
you a if he's giving you a precursor of
what's to come
and you can't sleep at night don't marry
this person or at least have some hard
conversations with a marriage therapist
really quick like premarital counseling
yeah yeah yeah we we do have a counselor
that that we talk to so that
yeah
you've got to get this to where he
um is demonstrating that he can stand on
his own
and uh
and because that's going to free every
time that's going to freak you out and
it's going to freak you out more than
everybody else it will freak out anybody
but it's going to freak you out even
more because of the way you're wired
right i mean you got to be kind of like
weighing like waking up at 2 30 in the
morning
right now right yeah did you did you
wake up i mean did you did you grow up
financially insecure
uh not insecure but my dad and mom like
they uh you know there was some um
cheating that happened so as a young kid
i was like that's it i'm gonna provide
for myself so at the age of eight i
started saving my money so let me tell
you this let me say this
that's trauma
and i want you to go to a counselor by
yourself
yeah and i want you to i want you to
tell them i need to learn how to
accept connection in my life and stop
relying on this imaginary pot of money
it's not imaginary the pot the pots
really safety's imaginary i want to
learn how to find security in
relationships and i've never been able
to do that and i need to learn those
skills that's your new assignment moving
forward yeah and and don't give people
money too that you're not married
to
he needs to go work extra
and he should want to
he should be he should be crazed about
it yes this is the ramsey show
[Music]
hey it's john deloni co-host of the
ramsay show did you know over 18 million
people listen to the ramsay show every
week a lot of those people listen on one
of our 600 plus radio stations across
the country to find a station near you
go to ramseysolutions.com
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsey show where
debt is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw as the status symbol of choice
i'm dave ramsey your host dr john
deloney number one best-selling author
of the brand new book own your past
change your future is my co-host today
as we talk about your building of wealth
your work doing work that you love
and creating actual
amazing relationships open phones at
triple eight eight two five five two two
five brian is in chicago hey brian how
are you
i'm good dave happy thursday happy
thursday to you what's up
uh so i just discovered your content
i've been binge watching it over the
past couple weeks
and decided to
make the decision to get really
aggressive about paying off my mortgage
so
i uh i got the a condo in chicago about
a year ago and i was looking over my
budget i feel like if i really get
aggressive and go on to you know the
beans and rice diet i could get this
thing paid off in two years wow um
so my my question though is
i've got about
30 something thousand saved in the
mutual fund i'm wondering if i should be
attacking this directly monthly with
payments
or if i should be putting it into the
mutual funds and then doing a lump sum
payoff in you know two two and a half
years
i would throw money at it as fast and as
hard as i could from every angle
not counting your emergency fund and i'm
assuming you're debt free other than the
condo
uh 15 000 student loans that i'm paying
off as well okay so i would cash out
them is the mutual fund in a retirement
account
uh no i have a 401k that i'm not
touching uh which is through vanguard
and i also have mutual funds through
vanguard yeah i would cash out the 30
000 and pay off the student loan today
i would build a a separate money market
account
as a
an emergency fund of three to six months
of expenses
i'd start putting 15 percent of my
household income and no more
into
uh
into your 401k and everything above that
i'm going to throw at the condo
monthly as fast and as often as i can
but anytime you can get your hands on a
lump sum that is not a retirement
account you throw it at that but it
sounds like this mutual fund money is
going to be used for other stuff you
have any money saved for emergencies
other than the mutual fund and the 401k
i have five thousand in a statement
account what do you make a year
um depending on bonuses in that uh about
110. good for you well you're doing
really good yeah you're doing good proud
of you so all we're doing is giving you
a fine-tuned program using the system
that we've used for 30 years with people
that's led people to become millionaires
it's called the baby steps baby step one
is a thousand dollars in the bank two is
debt free but the house so i immediately
went after your student loan three is
you build an emergency fund by adding to
the thousand dollar account of three to
six months of expenses in your house
that's fifteen or 20 000 bucks
and once you've got that rainy day fund
and no payments but a house payment you
move on to baby step four you put 15
percent of your income so 15 16 grand in
your case into good mutual funds in your
401k every year and above that any money
we can find in the budget i start
chunking it on the mortgage now that's
going to mean your mortgage does not pay
off in two years that's going to mean
your mortgage pays off in three to four
years which is just fine
how old are you
uh 31 oh you'll be 35 with a paid for
condo and you will have been putting
money in a mutual fund you'll have no
debt and you'll have an emergency fund
in place this is a beautiful picture
we're painting
and i would tell you this
you may be different than me probably
not
if i'm just i have another account or
i'm just dumping like i say you got a
thousand bucks a month extra every month
after you pay off your student loan and
you're just putting money in there and
you think i'm gonna pay off my mortgage
in ten thousand dollar chunks the
chances of you having nine thousand and
then somebody call and saying hey let's
go on a trip together that's just really
hard so i would pay that every month
whatever you got left i would pay that
as you go once you fill up that
emergency fund and not just save it for
these big chunks
john might see
a prius that he wanted to buy
and he would just run out and buy a
prius or he might see a deer rifle i
would i could be both yes
yes which are incongruent by the way but
it might
i told you such as john i'll tell you
such as john the first time i ever went
deer hunting and i got my first deer
i had shown up to the
place with my father-in-law and my son
and my wife's prius the deer processing
place and yeah i showed up to the deer
processor and i opened the back hatch
and it had a big 11 point buck in it and
this high school kid looks at me as
though i just pulled an alien out of the
car he said
sir i've never seen this before and i
was like it's not an 11-point [ __ ] that
he's never said dear honey goes no the
prius
yeah exactly
that's good incongruent incongruent i
like it christine is in springfield
illinois hey christine what's up
hey dave how's it going great how can we
help
well
my husband is 57
and i am 51
and we are debt-free including our home
it's worth probably about 270. wow good
for you guys
yeah we uh
we had a an accident several years ago
and ended up at the settlement so
we we paid off our home and then um put
some money into our retirement account
we've got about 1 million in our ira um
there's about a million in the 401k up
until probably this last few days
um
and
you know our kids our youngest is going
to be 21. kids don't have a bunch of
debt we've helped them as much as we
could they got good scholarships
but i had a family member die in the
last month and um so there's going to be
a chunk there
so
i'm guessing maybe 20 30 000 max what
should i do with that and now that we're
completely debt-free no credit cards
nothing like that
where should we put that several
thousand dollars a month
that we have just sitting in a bank
account because right now my husband's
like
i want to have cash on hand and i'm like
honey we have over a hundred thousand
dollars cash on hand we can't record it
in a bank account enough nothing yeah
prepper yeah
okay
so what do i do with those two bits yeah
and by the way we do have plenty of life
insurance his his um uh
his offer uh sorry his work offers
really good rates on term insurance okay
so we've even insurance we've got plenty
of term insurance on both of us you guys
have done a wonderful job
your everyday baby steps millionaires
very very very well done congratulations
can you call my husband and tell him
that he's afraid we're going to starve
yeah you're not literally he's so
nervous you're not going he's he's
afraid in retirement we're not gonna
have enough money to listen
turn the news off
time turn the notification turn the news
off walk away from the computer use the
audio get off the computer do not look
at all of the conspiracy theories okay
uh yeah he's gonna you're gonna be just
fine you're you've done a wonderful job
there are three things you can do with
money and you steadily ought to do that
with your monthly income and with this
inheritance
and i'd recommend you write it out in
both cases
take the dollar amount and give every
one of those dollars an assignment how
much of this is going to fund
how much of this is going to more
investing and how much is going to
generosity
i think your husband needs to increase
his fun and his generosity but you need
to be doing all three things
it'll be good for him to practice those
muscles they're kind of weak for him
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
chaos
that's what it can feel like when your
business is growing so fast you've
outgrown your financial and accounting
software the faster you grow the more
likely you are to lose control of the
numbers and here's the reality if you
don't know your numbers you don't know
your business that's why we use netsuite
by oracle the number one cloud financial
system over 28 000 companies use
netsuite by oracle including ramsey
solutions because netsuite gives us a
single view of everything we need to
make daily decisions whether you're
making a few million to hundreds of
millions a year netsuite gives you the
visibility and control of the things you
need to grow like your financials
inventory hr planning budgeting and more
all in one dashboard go to netsuite.com
ramsey right now to get their free
whitepaper jumpstart your cfo career
[Music]
so
[Music]
what do you do when you come across
something that helps you do life better
will you tell your friends about it
tell your relatives about it
at least the ones you like
when you find a great new gadget a
reliable mechanic a great restaurant a
good movie a book you tell your friends
about it because you don't want to miss
out well that's why the ramsay show has
grown to be one of the biggest
radio shows podcasts uh youtube in the
world
because millions like you tune in and
can help but share with your friends
and uh you tell everybody it's how you
changed your life thank you for that
and uh we appreciate you sharing how you
cut up your credit cards how you got out
of debt how you built wealth how you
saved money how you got your marriage
strengthened how you changed your career
hey all these things
and we appreciate that
and so if you found us on a podcast on
youtube on siriusxm your local radio
station wherever you found us
don't keep it to yourself please
share your favorite episode of the
ramsay show with your friends or family
so they can get the hope and the help
that they need because no one should
miss out on this
it's been working for a very long time
for millions of people
tuning in to the show right now is
somewhere between 20 and 25 million
people probably closer to 25 million
by the time this thing goes out in all
of its various forms
podcast youtube radio
all that and uh so it's it's not really
a big secret anymore but do spread the
spread the word and we would really
appreciate it we would be honored if you
would tell people about our show and
about the dr john deloney show and about
the ken coleman show about the rachel
cruz show and so on around here so hang
out with us but also tell folks
and uh if there's parts of it you don't
like or you don't want to you hate us
then don't listen
and don't please don't tell anybody
[Laughter]
anthony's in san antonio hey anthony
what's up
hey dave hey john pleasure to speak to
you both you too um so
quick uh background here i'm on baby
step number two me and my wife are our
household income is about 90k since
january we've been blessed the lord has
given us good jobs we've been able to
pay about a third of our debt so we've
got about 24k paid off already we've got
about 40 remaining
years ago before we realized how bad we
were with money
we did have a conversation with my
little sister about
going to las vegas for her 21st birthday
our hearts have changed completely we're
obviously trying to get out of debt
and
uh my whole family's going to vegas we
did the math we're really leaning
towards not going but at the same time
it's her 21st she's only and it's
probably going to be her last 21st
birthday or last
birthday ever before she gets married
she's in a very serious relationship
with a
delightful young man but
we just don't know what to do we
we did the math it'll probably set us
back
maybe a month not even a month if we
paid for this trip obviously we're done
with credit cards we're done with all
that so we're going to cash flow it if
we go but we're really
leaning towards not going so what's it
cost for guys
probably about 900
um
if we drive with gas prices i did the
map for that as well it
maybe save us like 30 or 50 bucks
we drive uh together tacoma
um i'm not sure
it would it seems like with the gas
prices we're spending 75 everything i
don't think you want to go not because
of money what's the other reason you
don't want to go
i i want to go
but i also
i it's just it seems like a lot with how
dedicated we've been to paying off debt
it seems like a lot of money to drop
to go do something that
my wife and i aren't even really that
pleasure i i don't know because i think
you don't want to go to vegas like you
don't want to go
part part of it but it's also my little
sister's birthday and my whole family's
going i feel a little bad how long are
they going to be there
there
if my wife and i are go we're only going
for a night they're going to be there
for like thursday through sun through
monday
my wife and i tonight
well
we would have to probably get a hotel on
the way out there as well just because
and on the way back if we drive because
plane tickets are absurd right now so we
would have to book a hotel on the drive
out there
look at the hotel on the way on the
drive back and then one hotel night in
vegas
i think that you want to want to go i
think you love the idea of celebrating
your sister i don't think you want to go
to vegas
whenever i don't want to do something i
inflate how much it's going to cost
by one and a half or two times i'm like
that's gonna cost a thousand bucks
probably 500 maybe 600 when i do want to
do something really big like i need this
new thing it's like uh it's probably a
hundred bucks and it's it's way more
than that
right something tells me you don't want
to go
you want to celebrate your sister but
you don't want to do the trip
i i guess that's partly true i mean me
and my wife kind of talked about even if
we let go we would probably
not go to the clubs and do things like
that that they would want to do because
obviously we're in debt and and to be
completely honest with you that's not
our scene uh we would love to go and see
the shows and things like that but but
the clubs and all that and drinking i
mean that's not something my wife and i
really partake in yeah
um
so they're
in that one
my little sister yeah yeah in that sense
john's right um
the only part of this that you want to
do is celebrate your sister you don't
want to do anything that they're doing
and you don't want to go
um other than just you do want to
celebrate her and that that's because
you're a good guy i mean that you should
you should want to do that that's a good
thing so dave you can tell me when it
comes to baby steps when it comes to a
milestone like this i wouldn't have a
problem it's going to set you back 25
days on your journey if you pay cash and
go and do your thing that didn't bother
me i also doesn't bother me if you have
your set of values and say hey we're not
going to do this thing
um
i hate it when somebody gets boxed into
an either or i just don't like
is there a way to do something different
but it doesn't sound like there is here
i don't know what to tell you to do this
different yeah um
yeah and it sounds like also the rest of
the family is going to be like
the weirdos are back at home
you know
yeah
yeah
that's you and then we know i know in my
parents i know that if i say hey but me
and claire's aren't going that's not
what i say we're not we're not going
dude you
we are in we're doing this dave ramsey
thing we're trying to get out of the
door don't blame it on me
yeah this is a choice brother
this one's on youtube
that's me okay and dave you may say
differently i would probably go and i
like you i don't i don't go to the clubs
i'm just not that's not my thing i
wouldn't do that and i i'm a nerd i go
to bed early and um but we'd go and
celebrate and have the dinner and say
it's great and then we'd head out early
um five nights in vegas or that's
that's a lot yeah um the other side of
it is don't blame anybody if you decide
to not go because of your values say we
don't really or we're not really
interested in going to there we'll
celebrate when she gets back uh we'll
have everybody over for dinner we're in
the middle of this thing and we're
getting out of debt and right now we
just can't do it i'm we're just sorry
and it's okay to say either one and it's
okay to cheap out on a couple of other
things and get the 900 down to 500 um
you know with your hotel choice or
whatever else and
um
it's also okay if your parents want to
pay for it if you want to go
that's okay there's nothing wrong with
that at all i'm thinking of a parent if
i'm if one of my kids was working on
something and they're saying hey we
don't want to go because we want to hit
this goal i'm like well if you would
like to go we really want to have you
we're not going to guilt you and i'll
cover it for you if you want to come
because we really want you there that
bad and um
that wouldn't bother me as a parent a
little bit yeah and so and i would hope
my child could could accept that uh but
if if that you know but if they say no
we just don't then i gotta i gotta
respect their boundaries and go no they
don't wanna come okay so that's okay and
and so i mean i've been in lots of
situations like this over the years with
family
i remember
sharon's family kept you know we kept
having more and more and more and more
grandkids on that side and so buying
gifts for every stinking person got to
be the federal deficit in the year the
year we went broke i just rolled into
sharon's parents house and sharon wasn't
even happy with me but i'm like hey we
can't do this we don't need money
uh we can draw names yes we'll draw
we'll buy for kids that are under five
and we're drawing names for the rest of
your goops
and uh
one of the other sisters goes well
finally somebody said it let's do it
that's right you know but i was
everybody's all worried that dave was
about to break the thing the family
tradition was about oh it's all gonna go
down in flames because of dave but it
turned out okay and now they've drawn
names for 20 30 years now you know so
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
dr john deloney ramsey personality is my
co-host today in the lobby of ramsey
solutions on the debt-free stage andrew
and courtney are with us hey guys how
are you hey
how are you welcome where do you guys
live we're from madisonville kentucky ah
okay up in the hopkinsville area welcome
to nashville and here to do a debt free
scream how much have you paid off 62
447 dollars and 16 cents i love it not
that we're counting
how long did it take you 22 and a half
months good for you and your range of
income during that time
from about 85
down a little bit and then back up to
about 95. cool what do y'all do for a
living
i'm in manufacturing i work for a ge
i
started out working for the orthodontist
in our town and then i switched to the
board of education ah okay and uh was
that a good raise
it was not
it took a lot of prayer and talk
we did a pros and cons list and it was a
pay decrease but we
adjusted our
our um
that was when it went down a little bit
yes and then it came back up yes okay
good yes sir very good good for you guys
what kind of debt was the 62 000
uh it's mostly uh there's a few credit
cards couple personal loans a couple
401k loans okay all right what were the
401k loans for what'd you buy uh
a lot of our debt stemmed from uh a
gambling addiction i had
so that's
you know that's what a lot of it was wow
wow
so what were you what kind of what were
you gambling what kind of game
uh just
any kind of sports online
yeah okay online stuff yes okay cool
what'd the healing journey look like on
the way out of that yeah how'd you break
that
uh
well we had we had hit a pretty rough
patch in our marriage we had some um
disagreements some arguments
and
when we got married we
joined our our finances together and
when i realized
the first couple of consolidated loans
that hit our bank account i was not
comfortable so i withdrew that's an
understatement you were the like queen
of understatement we had a rough power
not comfortable i almost killed him
a little bit we had a disagreement
there were some nights i looked at him
and was just like
so i took the high road and i took um my
money out of the bank account and opened
my own bank account opened up the kids
bank account and um
i still continue to see
no change i was still uncomfortable with
where things were going and so i reached
out to my sister-in-law
and
we
his sister yes his well his brother's
wife oh okay and um
and we
finally opened up his parents his
parents had no idea what was going on we
both kept it very hidden because we were
a little ashamed sure
and so we basically had a little
intervention for him and i just let out
everything that i was worried about and
they were kind of our
our go-betweens and so
they they really from the
the second that they knew everything
they were our support system and they
were our gods and how long ago was that
march 21st 2020
so your is your that's your that's your
dry date two years sober yes way to go
bro
congratulations man proud of you thank
you i'm proud of him too incredible i
wish you could see the way she's looking
at you
yeah it's so oogy it's making me
uncomfortable
she likes you a lot
incredible
so the uh
yeah that you so your family and your
wife come at you
and you just said okay they're right yep
i mean time to change yeah prior to that
you've been kind of uh ducking and
shucking and jiving and hiding and
am i right that's that's a normal
pattern anyway yeah
yeah
yeah so america in case you didn't know
the fastest growing addiction in america
today
is online porn the second fastest
growing addiction in america today is
online gambling it's tough and it's
those two things are destroying more
families than all drug addiction and
alcohol addiction put together
and the people don't understand the
numbers yeah
this is one of the evils of the internet
the internet's not evil in and of itself
but uh gambling has
exploded
and i can't tell you the number of times
one of our coaches is dealing with
someone who's trying to get out of debt
on one hand but on the other hand
they're really struggling particularly
sportsbook sportsbook is a big one
and so what you did what you had there
was not unusual i'm so proud of you man
that took a lot of strength so andrew
often people roll out of an addiction
and i don't say they trade addictions
but they lean into healthier behaviors
and it sounds like your healthier
behavior was hey let's let's let's get
on a path to help us get control back
right
and so tell us about that
yeah um that night i mean like she said
we you know we all met and um
had a long talk and that night i you
know i worked third shift at the time
and i was you know scrolling through
there and came across dave ramsey and uh
i'd heard the name before
uh but it never really listened to
anything and i started listening at
night and got hooked and like everything
you were saying was you know slapping me
usually when people say you got hooked
it's a good thing i'm not sure when you
say that i like you
but that was his healthy i'm kidding i'm
kidding with you
he did he came home from work and i
was barely awake and he said hey we're
gonna do this this is what we're doing
and i was like wow who
what
what i'm sleeping here i was like okay
we're okay sounds good so you were game
on then oh yeah and that gave you
something to focus on while you were
while you're moving those stuff now did
you go to like ga
no i didn't okay you see a coach a
counselor or anything nope i just just
said i'm stopping yeah well it made it a
little easier that was the start of the
pandemic and there were no sports going
on
that's so the supply dried up yeah a
little easier
well there you go that's that's true i
hadn't thought about that
so uh then you guys just lean in and
together you start doing the details now
how much further did you get plugged
into our stuff
um i uh after a couple weeks of
listening to podcasts just nonstop i i
bought a couple of the books and um
and i guess it was a few months later we
did a uh
fpu class with uh with our church oh
good okay yeah it took me a little while
to get heard on board with me
i can't believe what
yeah the the attic comes with another
scheme right yeah oh i got a plan i got
a plan right yeah it was read this book
listen to this podcast watch this on
youtube and i was like oh gosh well i i
you know what did i do yeah i got i got
her listening to rachel i was like if
you don't listen to dave you know i
think you'll like rachel she's you know
your age and she's funny and i think
you'll you'll like her you said it old
and grumpy right it's not funny yeah
we've got young cute and funny or old
and grumpy
hey so andrew yes you're not gambling
anymore no totally clean yes
when you're talking about it
your body folds up
with shame and guilt and today you walk
off that stage and you're going to leave
that crap right there right yes sir
you're done with it yes sir you're
announcing to everybody you're sobriety
and we're proud of you hey man i don't
want you carrying that stuff around i
could see it on you today you set it
down when you walk off that stage
that that's that guy used to be he's not
anymore game yep thank you that's fair
way to go guys thank you guys i'm so
proud of y'all we are honored to be a
little part of your huge journey you're
both very very courageous people and uh
you're you're impressive you're heroes i
mean the stuff you when you stare that
demon down and you beat it that's a
bigon and i honey i don't know where
they make you i don't know
you've you're one of one of a million
you're a saint i mean i had i except
except for the understatement
oh she can carry a house around with
understatement well i guess i guess i'll
just i'll just won't eat any dinner
tonight i guess i'll just go inside and
eat dirt i'll just wear the draper well
y'all thank you
that's right that's right
i mean i had i had my weaknesses too and
mine stemmed a lot from wanting my kids
to have what i didn't have growing up so
i
i'm not
guilt-free from getting a credit card
and saying hey you want to wear that
name brand outfit okay you want to go to
this place okay let's do it so
we really had to sit down especially
with our oldest and explain you know
it's not that we won't ever cut you off
because we're going to run up against
the clock here i want to make sure we
get your screen in sorry so we got all
the books and everything for you and
stuff for you to give away and stuff for
you to enjoy thank you so much for being
here thank you andrew and courtney
hopkinsville kentucky madisonville
kentucky 62 thousand dollars paid off in
22 months making 85-95 count it down
let's hear a debt free scream
three two one we're in the debt free
[Music]
those are two special people that you
freak very people free free people amen
free
in jesus name this is the ramsay shot
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
dr john dolone ramsey personality is my
co-host today as we talk about your life
and your money lindsay is with us in las
vegas hi lindsay how are you
how are you doing dave i'm doing good
good what's up
um i just got a quick question for you
maybe some advice for me if you have it
uh i currently own my house outright i
don't own anything on it
my dad and my grandpa helped me purchase
it i want to say in like 2013.
i currently don't have anything saved up
and i do need to make like some repairs
it's to that point where i had about two
thousand dollars in the savings which i
tried to spend to fix the roof to get
the insurance back on it so it's kind of
like now the insurance
has rejected me for the roof
that didn't work they still rejected it
and i have about maybe twenty thousand
dollars is what they quoted me to fix
some of the plumbing it's an older house
like 1963.
i'm thinking about selling it
and i kind of want to go back to school
because i'm only making about 25 000 a
year
i want to go back to school for
sonography which is like a two-year
course
and i'm thinking about maybe getting i
don't know something else to live in or
maybe rent
during that time frame all right you
want to pick your brain
33 okay why are you going to stenography
um
i kind of have a passion for it and i
wanted to get a better career going i'm
kind of just doing
whatever for right now that you know i i
do agree you need a new career i'm not
arguing with that i'm just wondering how
you pick stenography
um there's like medical field has always
been a passion of mine
i kind of i dipped my toes in the
the nursing for a little while
and i didn't really find that too
interesting but one of my friends had
gone to sonography and i kind of found
it really fascinating and kind of had an
interest in it what were your houses
what were your house so far as is
without doing the repairs
320 000
good i got a cash offer for it good lord
uh my concern with the uh stenography is
again this may be two years out maybe
five years out i'd hate for you to do a
two year program they're getting so
sophisticated with the
voice to text
software programs you might become
optional it feels like one of those
fields that in five years is going to be
really obsolete i may be incorrect there
but man that seems like a large
financial end and time commitment on
something that may just evaporate
underneath you okay let's let me put let
me put three or four ten thousand let me
put three or four facts on the table
okay okay fact number one
you have a house that needs a bunch of
repairs that you can sell for 300
something thousand dollars
fact number two you make twenty five
thousand dollars a year you have a
career that's a non-starter you need a
new career you need a path that is long
term
uh fact number three you're probably
going to have to do some kind of
training for some kind of new career
fact number four uh john and i are
calling a question mark on stenography i
want you to explore your career options
further before you make that part of the
decision
all those all sound like facts
definitely okay so i would agree you
need a new career i would agree to sell
the house go rent something and execute
some kind of a training program to move
into the new career
if i can
beg you to find five other things to
seriously consider in addition to
stenography because i think you pick
stenography without a lot of thought
okay i'm accusing you of that okay
all right
so um now what i would what i want to do
is i want to help you on the career side
because i don't you you got one shot at
this
if we sell the house and move into a
rental and you take off down some bogus
road on the career
then we blew the we you know we had one
bullet in the gun we already shot it and
the deer got away right you follow me i
totally agree it has to be something
that i'm definitely going to follow
through with and it's definitely going
to be well it needs to make you 300
grand
yeah
okay because you got 300 grand there
that we're betting on this we're not
going to spend all the 300 grand on it
but it needs to it you need to not make
25 anymore when we're done with this you
need to make a hundred
okay that's what i want for you and
lindsay i just heard it in your voice
you don't even think you're worth making
a hundred and you got two people telling
you you are you never even thought well
you may not be as a person you're worth
it but your skills may not be there yet
but i think you're trainable into some
skill set that'll get you there
definitely i totally agree yeah all
right so here's we're gonna i'm gonna
send you a copy of ken coleman's book
from paycheck to purpose and we're also
gonna sign you up to take the career
assessment now he has a seven-step
process for figuring out about the
career
the first step is to become clear
on what it is you what you're what you
what it is you're gonna do and are the
first the third step but the first two
steps are getting to know yourself and
really guiding into that so i want you
to pick a career that um
that has a huge upside
and that that is something that as you
start talking about it it makes you it
makes you smile
your heart starts beating
when you start talking about it and the
pay is really good
definitely okay but i don't want you to
get something that pays really good that
you hate and i don't want you to get
something that you think you love that
sucks on the pay
because you should make a lot of money
at something you love
anytime you can do that in life you have
really got it dialed in and that's what
i want for you so you hang on kelly will
pick up we're going to get you the
career assessment by ken coleman i want
you to jump on ken coleman.com and start
read everything on his website about
finding and getting the right kind of
job what is the training necessary once
you identify what it is then you back up
and you start identifying what the
training is and we've got 300 000 to do
that with and we're not trying to fix up
a house for 20 and 40 and 60 000 worth
of repairs on 25 000 income which just
sounds exhausting and lindsay
whatever you do
when you sell this house
you're going to have a 300 000 check
deposit in your checking account don't
touch it no cars no shopping sprees no
running down to the strip no vacations
that's not what that money is for that
stuff can it will go away like sands
through an hourglass
don't spend it it'll go up like flash
paper you'll be you'll look up now a
year it's gone so you can only spend it
on two things
bare bones necessities food shelter
clothing
and education to accomplish your career
goal that's the only two things you're
allowed to spend it on don't you touch
it
except that i'll come i'll come i'll
come smack you don't you touch it
because this is your shot girl we want
that for you all right that's it don't
you touch it
all right i'm kidding with you but
seriously kiddo this is dangerous what
we're playing with here and john's right
it can get away from you so you hang on
and kelly will pick up and we'll get you
signed up for all of ken's stuff and
start listening to ken coleman show call
ken and talk to him he'll help you with
this
or call in when he's on this show one
time he'll help you it's what he does
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five
two two five earl nightingale used to
say a thousand years ago in that old
talk that i often reference it's the
first million selling talk ever done
the strangest secret
he said it used to say that no it's not
in the strangest secret it's in a uh
it's in another talk he did where he
said what you can conceive and believe
you can achieve but in that talk he says
um
people spend more time
picking out a suit of clothes
than they do their future career in that
wild
they spend they spend time obsessing for
days on the internet
picking out something getting the right
shirt getting the right thing there
wasn't an internet then but i mean today
that's what they do rather than
sitting and really
looking inward
the unexamined life is not worth living
socrates said looking inward and
figuring out what it is i'm made to do
under ken coleman lingo right and what
is it i've got talon at and then going
and getting the training to accentuate
that and moving into a career field that
every monday morning you're smiling yeah
that's right
it's it's in the same with picking a
spouse we'll spend four years dating or
two years dating and we'll spend like
well
dad was this uh i guess i'll just try
that yeah or i got this job in college i
guess someone said stay here i was at
the bar drinking beer and they said
they're hiring down there that's right i
went on 38 years later i'm still there
that's right you know oh my god this is
not how you pick what you're going to do
with your life yep
you know it's
you know
you're you're a friend your friend who
is a dead-end dub you're going to be
just exactly like him if you go to work
at the same place doing the same stuff
he's doing
you know oh my gosh don't do this people
and lindsay's not going to we're going
to make sure because this is the ramsay
show
[Music]
hey it's john delonie co-host of the
ramsay show did you know over 18 million
people listen to the ramsay show every
week a lot of those people listen on one
of our 600 plus radio stations across
the country to find a station near you
go to ramseysolutions.com
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsay show where
debt is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw as the status symbol of choice
this is the ramsey show where we help
people build wealth do work that they
love and create actual
amazing relationships dr john deloney
ramsey personality host of the dr john
deloney show and author of the number
one best-selling book own your past
change your future is my co-host today
thank you for joining us at triple eight
eight two five five two two five josh is
with us josh is in charlotte north
carolina hey josh how are you
hey dave hey john how are you guys doing
better than we deserve sir what's up
so i think i know what your answer is
going to be dave long time listener um
but i wanted to hear it from your voice
my wife and i have talked about um i
just wanted i just want a verification
we have talked about with the current
state of the stock market uh we're both
investing we're debt-free we're
investing 15 plus percent at our
retirement
we've talked about potentially
pausing our retirement in order to pay
off our house in about 30 years
um what's your household i wanted to see
we make about 120 okay and what's the
balance on your home
about 75
okay so i know i know dave you would say
we could pause other things
and and keep the retirement and uh and
keep it going but we have been through
the gazelle phase
we okay you said you said you would pay
it off in this you said you paid off in
three years
yeah we could pay it off in about three
years three years of 15 of your income
is only 45 000. where's the rest of it
coming from
sorry i'm not sure i'm following what
you're saying okay seventeen thousand
dollars is fifteen percent of a hundred
and twenty
seventeen times three is forty five
forty six thousand dollars forty seven
thousand dollars okay
so that's not seventy five thousand
dollars so you've already are paying
extra on your mortgage
yeah we've already paid an extra on our
mortgage so you're paying about 10 000
15 000 extra on your mortgage now
yes yes okay
and you said 15 plus percent why plus
just to chunk a little bit of extra
money in there
okay so if you backed it down to
actually 15
we would increase it a little bit right
a little bit yes okay all right and so
the difference is if we do this is three
years or if we only put uh 20 000
towards it it's five years
they're they're about yes yep so we have
a three-year or a five-year equation
so the difference the the discussion is
two years difference
yep
the stock market's on sale right now the
last thing i'm going to do is quit
putting money into it yeah i was going
to ask
and i'm asking uh josh i'm asking dave
this question
i'm hearing now if you've got money to
put in now's the time yeah because all
the stocks are at discounts i don't try
to time the market exactly but i i it is
always exciting to me when the market
drops right
because i'm not taking my money out i'm
only putting more in the more you put it
in a bargain that's right it's on sale
you know when we were kids the blue
light would come on at kmart and they
would have a sale blue light sale on
there's a blue light sale on the stock
market right now and so that that's uh
there's not in kmart there's nothing
blue lights anymore i know i know i know
okay don't send me more dadgum tweets
about being a boomer okay i'm with you
but the uh i get it i get it but the
point is it's on sale whatever whatever
it is you want to flash sale on amazon
whatever you want to compare it to
ramsey 10 sale i don't know whatever it
is but yeah i you're right josh you
didn't know what i was going to say
i'm not going to pause your retirement
for two years of gain
because the other thing that we haven't
used in this equation is we have not
added into this equation all the
wonderful financial things that are
going to happen to you in addition to
your 120 000 worth of income during this
five years that turn the five years into
four or three
a bonus
an unexpected small inheritance
a uh a windfall here or there of some
kind oh by the way your income's
probably going to go up during this five
years a side hustle and we've not we've
not done any of that yeah we've not
mentioned any of that here and all of
that's going to turn the five years into
four into three
my prediction is that if you keep
putting no more than 15 percent not plus
and you look at your budget and you
don't go gazelle intense i'm not
suggesting you cut out a bunch of other
things if you keep doing what you're
doing add a little bit here that used to
be there just take a few take a little
fluff off the sides not not any hard
cuts just tighten it up pay attention
make sure you're doing a written budget
because sometimes people get sloppy here
at four through seven they kind of relax
on the budget a little bit actually be
doing the budget every single month
and uh do be enjoying you're intentional
you're not intense
but
my prediction is still between three and
four years your house is going to be
paid for
that's what i think is going to happen
because i think there's some things
coming your way because it usually does
follow
that god blesses people who are being
trustworthy stewards
so can you give a quick primer i hear
the i hear that it's on sale
what does that actually mean
well uh okay the the market is down in
the last five years we pull up the
charts today the market's down 5.82
percent in 12 months okay okay so let's
say it goes down 10 percent
uh and if you put in
a hundred thousand dollars and it goes
back up
to where just to where it was
on its way north
um when it goes back up right just to
where it was on its way north then you
will have made
an extra 10 or 20 thousand bucks so if
i'm buying if i've been i'm in this is
simple for i'm trying to smooth it out
for me if i've been buying apple stock
at a dollar and it goes down ten percent
you can buy it for 90. i'm buying it for
90 cents yeah and then when it goes back
to a dollar a dollar five yeah no i
bought the same stock just exactly there
you go okay you would have paid the
dollar for it you got to you got on sale
for 90. right and you'd have been happy
at a dollar yeah that's right you know
and that's true of a good mutual fund
you have that same i'd have been happy
at 36 000 dow
i'm happy at a
one thousand 34
two thousand dow to jump in and because
i'm not getting out right i'm riding it
long term but not getting out and i'm
continuing to put monies in the slot
machine not sloppy that's a bad analogy
i'm continuing to put money in yeah
you're chunking money and you're
dropping the quarters in yeah so
warren buffett and a bunch of other
people had things to say when the market
dove in 2008 and it went from 13 000 and
went in half down to 6 300. 50 dropped
yeah and they said well mr buffett
you've lost all you've lost this much
money on berkshire hathaway stock you
know you've lost a you know whatever was
a half a billion dollars and he said i
haven't lost anything
i haven't sold anything sold anything
that's right if i sell it i've locked in
the losses
but right now the value is down but i
haven't sold it
if you own a house and the house goes
down in value you don't lose money on
the house until you sell it right
now if you wait on it to come back up
then you didn't lose money on the house
and and that's what's going on with the
stock market so hey that works in
reverse i've had i've got buddies you're
like man i made a million dollars on my
house and my thought is you made
anything you haven't sold it yet that's
right you haven't you haven't made any
money so don't start spending that money
that you think you've made you haven't
made anything that's right your equity
has increased your net worth has
increased but you haven't made anything
that's right
yeah you have to turn it into real money
and then you made some money and i made
a lot of money on bitcoin then i lost a
lot of money on bitcoin you didn't
really do either one you just watched it
go up and down that's right
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
if you're looking for ways to update
your home without blowing the budget
i've got it for years i've been telling
you about our friends at blinds.com
blinds.com makes it simple to shop top
quality blinds shades and interior
shutters from home with easy online
ordering and free shipping with
blinds.com there's no need to renovate
your entire home just change out what's
on your windows with upscale choices
like faux wood blinds cellular and
roller shades or even outdoor shades
plus blinds.com guarantees the perfect
fit whether you do it yourself or you
have them measure and install everything
for you shop their latest looks and see
how much you can save at blinds.com
today the easy and affordable way to
make your home more beautiful is
blinds.com
[Music]
so
[Music]
well it's one of the best times of the
year here at ramsey we're giving away up
to three thousand dollars during our
ramsey cash giveaway and we're
discounting our best-selling books for
only ten dollars to only ten dollars
that's a sixty seven percent discount
and why do we do this because we wanna
make it as easy as possible for you to
crush your goals okay john what's the
last thing you bought for 10 bucks
oh me and blake thompson and pete young
went out to a concert the other night
and i got a like a hot dog kind of thing
and it was so basically i bought uh
indigestion for ten dollars is what i
got
have you hey can you think of a thing no
that you can buy no i mean an item not
an item because i mean you get a cup of
coffee for under ten bucks yeah a hot
dog for ten bucks but i can't think of a
an item hardly that i mean a pack of gum
yeah that that you know that again
that's something you ingest i guess but
yeah i don't know what items you buy
today i'm trying to think of things i've
bought last few months like a pair of
pants and a pair of shoes and some
bullets and some uh you know bullets
each were listed nothing is ten bucks
yeah
each single bullet is less than ten
dollars barely not much barely yeah yeah
it's yeah you can't get anything for ten
bucks man yeah doesn't get you much
anymore but you get a lot here uh 22 you
can go the movies 15 you can get a pizza
maybe
you could get about two and a half
gallons of gas
that's mine
drive around the block yeah and uh or
you could get the total money makeover
for 10 and learn how to handle a lot
more than 10 bucks or you could
questions for humans conversation cards
and spend hours of laughing and having
real conversations with your kids your
spouse your friends by dr john delony
only 10 bucks your copy of the total
money makeover for ten bucks could save
you thousands of dollars could put you
on the path to being a millionaire check
out the ramsey ten dollar sale don't
forget to enter the ramsey cash
giveaway
joseph is in dallas hi joseph welcome to
the ramsay show
hi dave and john i really appreciate all
the great work you both do thanks how
can we help
so um yeah so i am currently on the baby
step 3b
meaning that i'm saving for a house um
i am looking to relocate though from
dallas uh it's not that it's not
treating me well but i'd like to
relocate to another state namely
cleveland ohio to be closer to the
family that i have there i've been
attempting to relocate now for about a
year a little over a year
and i'll be fine i'm not getting getting
any traction i'm not getting making any
progress i've started reaching out to a
lot of people that are in my field i've
applied to companies and i'm just not
getting anything back i'm so i'm
starting to feel discouraged by it and i
just wanted to call you you know both
for some guidance
uh encouragement you know plan so that i
don't just pick up and move because we
always know that if you don't have
something solid lined up it's you know
bad idea not a smart move yeah what's
your field
i um manage teams lead teams on
political campaigns and i actually
really enjoy my i enjoy the work that i
do
okay so you your your
jobs are usually let they move from
uh candidate to candidate i assume
yeah correct either based upon the
candidate or they based upon policies
uh sometimes association but usually
it's usually you know somebody around
that gets you the next gig
and the trick is you just don't know
anybody in that are you doing state
level races or uh local races yeah most
mostly my races have taken me all over
actually it's just it's just it's
unfortunate that i have not been able to
really connect with i've tried to
connect with people in the ohio area
and uh i've gotten conversations but no
callbacks but you're doing state level
stuff
correct yeah it's mostly correct it's
mostly for congressional camp you know
so sometimes senate people sometimes
congressional people uh and mostly it's
mostly been within the texas area
correct okay so u.s senate u.s congress
not texas
oh
those two those two like yeah right
right now i'm managing oh i know i'm on
a campaign for a local congressional
race uh and sometimes i'll be on for
like say a mayor's race so and so forth
joseph here dave hopping here here's my
thoughts on this and i'm going to use
your particular
situation to extrapolate a larger issue
that i'm hearing over and over and over
i am a teacher
and i live in x town
and the houses in x-town have tripled in
value and i can't buy a house
um i
want to be by my family and i do this
particular career and i love it but i do
it another state and i want to i want to
get into this market and so what i'm
feeling is a tension between three
things
the life i want to live this picture i
have of my life in your case i want to
make x by my family
the second intention is geography and
the third tension is income and so i'm
just gonna roll back to when i was a
high school teacher i was a basketball
coach and a track dude i loved that job
it was so great
and
it was down the street from where i grew
up which wasn't great
and they handed me a worksheet that said
in 42 years here's what your income will
be
and i said i i don't want to do that
life
right so one of the variables had to
shift and so i ended up transitioning
out of a job that i loved that i think i
would have been good at um because of
one of those variables and so for me if
you're saying i've been trying this for
a year trying to get into this thing you
can continue to try to make contacts but
the question you got to ask yourself is
you said
you want me and dave to tell you
something so you don't pack up and move
that's not how life works brother you're
just gonna have to decide to be a grown
up and not do something dumb right
there's nothing we're gonna tell you not
do something dumb what i want you to say
is how badly do you want to be by family
is it enough to do a different career or
job for a while if it's not great man
then
let yourself off the hook there but
you're trying to force a round peg into
a square what do you mean
on average between 55 to 60.
okay
all right
well let me ask you this
the bad news is uh uh or the good news
is that's not an income that's that hard
to replace in other fields right
so you probably could land something if
you want to move home and be with family
in a different field with the goal of
beginning to
you know kind of working your way up
from the bottom in the political world
and getting back in five years to where
you are but in the ohio market that's a
possibility and use ken coleman's
proximity principle with that in mind
um
but yeah that's uh i i think you could
probably you know you're you know how to
lead teams and drive product projects
you can drive campaigns for anything you
don't have to drive them per capita you
can deal with a politician leading you
can work for anybody
right yeah this is high stress high
urgency
uh you know deadline driven stuff and
you're a team project manager and that a
lot of those actually make a lot more
than 55 000. so you probably could do
that in corporate america and um get a
level of enjoyment and a good income be
near family meanwhile nights and
weekends you know you start you know
start making the contacts and you go
work the volunteer stuff and you do yeah
whatever you got to do
with the with that group up there and
continue to use some of your old
contacts to get your foot in the door
and so on so yeah that's probably what
i'm gonna do is is what john said try to
change one of the variables uh in order
to make this happen or you just say
you know i'm probably not going to be
able to do it in a way
in cleveland that i'm going to be happy
with and so i'm not going to cleveland
yeah it's that it's finding your piece
among those variables of
income and geography and the job that
you want to have right that life you
want to have yeah those three things
heart which one's it going to be so good
question open phones at triple eight
eight two five five two two five there's
a lot of interesting stuff in history by
the way and we're seeing it happen right
now again
of people doing just what we're talking
about
um
dust bowl
during the 30s
the uh
detroit factories opened up for cars
mass production was going
and the people that were cart cotton for
farmers that were making absolutely
nothing in
west bygott arkansas
uh
got in a car and went to detroit i've
had thoughts about the potato farmer in
ireland that said i don't know what's
four weeks away i'll buy boat but it's
better than this it's better than me
starving today again i'm getting the car
this is the third time in seven year
cycles in 21 years that i've had a
potato famine three in a row by the way
i'm out the
try something else and so we end up with
um can you imagine that scotch scots and
scots irish all over philly man they're
coming up the before there was a new
york city uh they're landing there in
the 1700s and filled up this place and
so that's a diaspora we're seeing it now
driven by politics we saw it after
katrina we have uh cajun restaurants all
over the world man houston because they
left we left new orleans never to return
after katrina they're leaving california
because of whatever never to return
they're leaving new york right now never
to return covet draconian mandates and
crazy politics and they're out of there
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
dr john dolone ramsey personality is my
co-host today
thanks for hanging out with us america
in the lobby of ramsey solutions which
you are more than welcome to visit
anytime we have a visitor center and on
any given day we have 50 to 200 folks
watching the show live we broadcast it
live every day from 1 to 4 central time
as a visitor center with free cookies
and oh they're good
and of course great coffee everything's
on us we want you to come by hang out
see the whole history of this place and
uh get plugged in on the debt free stage
nick and rose are with us hey guys how
are you good good welcome welcome where
do you guys live
plain minnesota okay which is near
minneapolis correct okay cool welcome to
nashville and how much debt have you
paid off 180
seven hundred
ah leo aren't messing around a hundred
and eighty thousand or eighty eight
hundred and eighty eight seven hundred
okay all right all right cool and how
long did this take you
50 months all right good and your range
of income during that time 180 000 to
222 000 good for you what do you guys do
for a living
i'm a master electrician by
trade i do instrumentation and control
work
very good i'm a police officer good for
you awesomeness well thank you guys very
cool proud of you that's a lot of debt
in 50 months uh am i guessing right you
pay off your house yeah yeah weird
people
hey look we got the police officer to
smile just a little bit it was hard yeah
we did it we did it what's this house
worth uh the county says it's uh four
hundred and eighty thousand dollars yeah
what do you think it's really worth
though county's not right night
i don't know it's worth over 500.
easy
yeah all right so uh and how much you
guys got in your retirement funds
seven hundred thousand i'm looking at
millionaires yep one of you is a
policeman and the other one's a master
electrician that does instrumentation
how old are you two
43
almost 42. and you're millionaires baby
steps millionaires i'm so proud of y'all
that's so cool man
it's everywhere baby it's everywhere
i love it way to go you guys all right
tell us the story what happened five
years ago they got this whole thing
going well i was a
few years back i was driving home from
my cousin's house just got done wiring
his garage and i was listening to this
radio show i didn't know what it really
was and then
about a year later my buddy's like hey
check out this guy
and so he puts you on and i'm like
that's the guy i heard coming back from
my cousin's house and
sorry listen to i think i listened to
you for about two years before we
finally started the plan and i
talked to the wife and
um i think you were a swear word in the
house for a little bit
but
she quickly came on board and
i calculated it all out i'm like okay we
can get our consumer debt so we had two
car loans we could get that paid off in
the air and it's going to take the house
uh
five years so it's a six year plan and
we ended up doing in 50 months so just
over four years four years yeah yep and
it was it was weird because as we're
doing the plan um
you just end up finding extra
extra money you know once you start
becoming intentional
it's amazing on um how you find where
other where it comes from i i don't know
it's just it was weird yeah okay so so
rose what's your part of the story how
did he he wore you out for a little
while sounds like
i always just felt like we were pretty
intentional with our money to begin with
um neither one of us were ever
people who just randomly went out and
bought things that we didn't need it was
always just if we needed it
rarely bought anything that we didn't um
so it felt like we weren't really making
any changes but i guess now looking back
like i am excited to be able to uh get
new kitchen cabinets yeah things like
that yeah but yeah now that you're there
huh yep so that's the first big purchase
now
got one of them yep something that
really you need to do something to
celebrate i mean you're millionaires and
you're debt free 100
how does it feel to not have a payment
in the world
awesome yeah what do you tell people the
key to getting out of that ass
uh i would say just
stay on track um
budget that makes a big difference
knowing where your money goes
and just you know
need purposes
sticking with it yeah you guys are two
pretty matter-of-fact people i mean
there's just no bs in your house hey
hold on though i i gotta ask this you've
been working on this for 50 months
being an officer in minneapolis the last
few years minneapolis has been hell
yeah your world came to a screeching
halt 24 months ago being an electrician
and when they said you can't work
and you all kept plowing through this
how did y'all do that because you all
would have had to lean on each other in
a way that is uncharacteristic for most
most of us wouldn't have been able to we
would have said pause because the
world's on fire literally
y'all kept going how'd you do that
just one foot in front the other you
know uh
work my i was lucky the industry that
i'm in you know we had to keep showing
up every day
um
so
and then just being support for her
because
yeah it was a difficult time
yeah y'all two remind me of lake wobegon
characters like just gonna get up and
just go one step
one step after the other man's fantastic
y'all are midwest at his finest
wonderful man good stuff goes incredible
so did you tell other people who were
your biggest cheerleaders uh my buddy
mike uh the one that told you to turn it
on
yeah yeah i love it yeah and then uh
a guy at work jim uh i got him listening
to the show and we
could have some conversations you know
it's kind of difficult too to talk to
people about finances and and then your
plan because
it's abnormal right because you're
winning too yeah and that people don't
talk about who'd you bring with you over
here
our neighbors okay all right cool
they've been hearing about you guys for
quite a few okay years yeah all right so
they came to the trip to nashville to
tag along and cheer you on today yeah
very good well congratulations you guys
thank you very very very proud of you
it's very cool i can sense what i can
sense why you did this your steadiness
you're just very predictable very steady
um and you know you don't quit
and it gets tough you just bear down
keep going and that's what you were
doing in your careers that's what you
did through the pandemic through all the
stuff you've been through as a police
officer everything else and uh
congratulations you're very strong
people
and
we all promise to go have some fun yeah
yes good that's right we're here we just
got here this morning so now we got the
rest of the couple days all right enjoy
nashville there's plenty here to enjoy
that's awesomeness and hit downtown
franklin right up the road it's a lot of
fun so we got a copy of baby steps
millionaires for you because you should
have been in there it's your book next
chapter in your story it is the chapter
in your story we're also going to give
you a uh one-year subscription to ramsey
plus which gets you into every dollar
and the financial piece uh you probably
have been through it or may want to go
through it again or maybe you want to
give that to somebody maybe you know
somebody's just getting started on this
same thing with the book total money
makeover we're going to give you all of
that to say
congratulations we're so
very proud of you nick and rose
minneapolis minnesota 189 thousand
dollars paid off their baby steps
millionaires in their early 40s making
did that in 50 months making 180 to 122.
oh and there was a pandemic oh and a few
other things going on up there count it
down let's hear a dead free scream three
three two one we're the free
yeah
[Applause]
that is fun
i love it that is great stuff
very very well done i mean that's that's
uh
it's mental health 101 dave oh i just
put one foot in front of the other and
kept going man i just got other stuff to
do here and um
oh yeah she's having a hard time i guess
i'll be there for you guys i'll be there
for yeah i'm just going to keep moving
forward we made it going we're going to
make it happen uh yeah he's not working
but well i'll do something else i'll
work something else and yeah it'll be
okay and you just kind of just got to
keep going keep going there's just no
drama there's no drama drama is not
allowed you know we got to get the
tortoise doesn't have drama this is
going to shock you dave but i'm the
exact opposite
[Laughter]
me too that's why we end up teaching
this stuff because god wants to keep us
both on track we're married to stable
people
well that's true
that's true and that's helpful as well
i'm so excited good news there i mean i
mean they went through
a lot of really hard tough season we
don't laugh at it i mean it's very tough
tough tough season and still paid off
their stinking house man that's right
and still became millionaires they're
curve busters man they they're they take
people's excuses away yeah you know what
i mean i love folks like that's
incredible it's like you know and then
there's nick and rosie that's right this
is the ramsay show
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
matthew 7 11 is our scripture of the day
if you then though you are evil know how
to give good gifts to your children how
much more will your father in heaven
give good gifts to those who ask him
charity said should our thomas fuller
said charity should begin at home
but should not stay there
rc's with us in costa rica hey rc what's
up
great dave how are you better than i
deserve how can we help
well it's a true honor to be on the
phone with you and i also want to know
john you are a great value add to the
program love listening to you thank you
so much how can we help so
my question is
how do you deal with the emotion
of your asset values and the crazy
fluctuations we're seeing in the stock
market these days
you know i'm i'm an everyday millionaire
it took me probably
20 years of hard work
to build up a million dollars in the
nest egg and i've well sort of surpassed
that now but now you watch over the
course of four months and you can see a
million dollars eradicate out of your
investment balance
almost seemingly overnight and so whoa
whoa
whoa whoa whoa
how did you lose
you got 20 million dollars in
investments
well i had six million
okay market's down marcus down was six
percent in a 12-month period of
time but it's down
18
since
january 1st no it's not
it's down 6 in a 12 month period of time
it wasn't back up that far
so over the last four months it's down
18 though
uh
let's see 36 to
31
yeah um
yeah probably 15. okay
so but that's still not a million on six
million is it
yeah i guess it is okay close enough my
mouth knows it like that yeah you're
pretty close okay i'm back with you okay
so the bottom line is though uh how do i
deal with it i didn't even know it until
i looked it up a minute ago um
so i don't i don't track it day by day
by day because you're not using this
money day by day by day
and the money the fact that you are in
the market and have been in the market
for years you have ridden these waves
before
what is it about this one that's got you
so troubled
well i think what happens is you know as
you do grow
your wealth
the numbers become a bit more
astronomical when you start thinking
back
to
where you started yeah do you realize
though that you picked the highest point
in 12 months to compare to the lowest
point
in 12 months
no i understand that your emotions
picked the emotions picked the worst
possible scenario in any anywhere in the
entire 12 months much less anywhere in
the past 10 years
no i'm certainly not arguing with you
about that it's the anchoring bias where
you attach to
the best it's an anchoring mice i
understand that yeah it's human nature
to anchor
what i don't okay you ask how i deal
with it emotionally
number one i'm always looking forward
from it and i'm not concerned about a 31
000 dow any more than i was concerned
about a 36 000 dial
i.e a 15 shift since january
the 4th it appears to be the high date
i'm sitting there pulling it up while
we're talking about it but i didn't even
looked at it before today until you
called
because i thought your i thought your
numbers were bs but they're not so
but
because most the time people exaggerate
their numbers when they're going down
because they're in freak out mode
there's a psychological study done years
ago that says you have to recoup three
dollars for every dollar lost to feel
even
lost losses weigh heavy on your
overstates yeah losses are you get more
credit for losses in your emotions than
you do in your increases so i'm always
just looking out i'm going okay how old
are you rc
um 54 almost okay so you're you know i'm
61. um i don't have as long as you got
probably and i'm not worried about it
because i'm looking out 20 years 10
years i mean if i got 6 million in the
market it's going to go up a lot during
that next 20 10 years and you're really
not pulling it out today i'm not i'm not
bailing out on it uh can i ask you a
quick question hey hey rc
um sure
are you is there a chance you're going
to get out
that you would you would catch me i've
got good financial advisors they won't
they won't let me do that so i've got a
strong
okay it's just the emotion it's just the
emotion of the click on the on the
website and you go oh my god yeah okay
so let me let me say this yeah if i know
that i'm not going to take action b
then i am not going to
spend the emotional energy on consuming
actionable data on that variable
see what i'm saying
if i'm never gonna jump out of the
market unless my financial advisor calls
me and says hey this is world war three
get out now
if that short of that
i'm i i didn't know it was down 15
because i don't look because i'm never
getting out what i put in there
you see what i'm saying and so the
emotional energy i don't even i don't
even put that those dollars on the table
because i'm never going to spend them
yeah emotionally it's a good point and
it is the thing rc it's a great question
by the way great question and i
apologize for calling your number bs
because it really wasn't i'm the more
i'm looking at playing with it while
we're sitting here catching up with i
don't look but um the uh but with the
data points you're using your numbers
are accurate um but i don't look at it
and it's the same thing we're talking
about in an earlier segment warren
buffett when the market dropped in uh in
2008 2000 2078 it went from 13 000 to 6
500 is down 50 they said mr buffett you
know berkshire hathaway you lost
x number of billions of dollars and he
goes i lost anything and sold anything
because i didn't sell it that's right
yeah and i'll say you unlocked anything
yeah you haven't lost a thing you've
lost the perception of yeah or the
perceived value of
yeah and um you know the only reason
that you would be uh
freaked out about this is if you felt
like it was a trend that was going to
continue i don't
uh i don't know i mean it might go down
for two years we may be in a recession
biden may screw up everything for a
while and it'll come along somebody else
and they'll have their own version of
screwing it up and so you know it's just
um i prospered under every president
and every party in spite of all of them
is the way i look at it and you've had
down seasons probably across every
president right yeah and you know i went
broke during ronald reagan there you go
you know i mean you know and i'm a
breaking fan yeah some of the stuff he
did was nasty bad for the world i was in
mary is with us in jacksonville florida
hi mary welcome to the ramsay show
thank you dave thank you for taking my
call sure i'm a little short on time go
straight to your question please
well what do you do when
your husband knows that you don't
support co-signing a loan for your 20
year old son who just moved back with
you and then you find out after the fact
when you ask what's the status that he
went ahead and signed a loan
please find along with our son so what
do you do when your husband deceives you
on something that means a lot
about it
exactly yeah this is called financial
infidelity
he violated your trust
yes he did yeah i'm sorry and he says
it's personal the reason i didn't want
to do it because my son and i have
always butted heads
uh mary has he done this before on other
things
yes yes
a long time ago yes these things rarely
happen in a vacuum and so you're
bringing all of that history back to
this moment and it's fair to do right
because he violated your trust again and
i'm so sorry yeah
so i don't know what to do i i don't
know i was like i had already told him i
said it's extremely dangerous and i
don't support it more of a kid doesn't
even have a a regular job he he does
door dash
it doesn't matter what yeah
your son is not in the equation not
about math this is your husband lying to
you yeah
again this feels like he had an affair
it activates the exact same place in
your emotions
yes it does yeah
so treat it like you've had an affair
and that means you need to go see a
marriage counselor
and he needs to go too
because this is this is activating
exactly the same level of trust we see
it all the time and i gotta tell you he
has no idea because he's blind as a bat
how much damage he's doing
because he thinks this is innocent and
he just overrode you because you were
emotional and weren't using good
judgment and he disagreed with your
decision but
all of that was used in his mind to
justify his affair
and it feels the same way i'm so sorry
honey yeah i know this hurts hear me and
dave say
the hurt you feel is real it's valid so
you should be hurt and you should be
angry and uh you need to go see a
marriage counselor and so does he
desperately
this is not going to end well if you
guys don't work through this
that puts this hour of the ramsey show
in the books we'll be back with you
before you know it in the meantime
remember there's ultimately only one way
to financial peace and that's to walk
daily with the prince of peace christ
jesus co-host of the ramsay show did you
know over 18 million people listen to
the ramsay show every week a lot of
those people listen on one of our
600-plus radio stations across the
country to find a station near you go to
com slash ramseysolutions.com
[Music]
you